Whitney wolf herd co-founder of bumble
was once known as the queen bee of
dating apps women can make the first
move women are equal and that's why we
set out to do that in dating and then
friendship and here we are at business
and networking but now just 6 years
later wolf herd will be stepping down as
the dating app company's CEO and sliding
into a new role while bumbles Growing
Pains as a public company
continue formerly the youngest self-made
female billionaire ever The Firm
announced on November 6th that wolf herd
will exit her current post as chief
executive and become bumble's executive
chairwoman on January
2nd the move follows an extended slide
for Bumble stock since the company's
initial public offering in February
20121 at that time the dating app held a
nearly $9 billion valuation but at
Friday's Market close bumble's
$13.67 share price was 83% below its
all-time high of 7
$8.89 achieved in its first week of
trading the 34-year-old wolf herd saw
her own fortune tumble as Bumble shares
cratered losing her billionaire
status bumble's stock slid 9% to about
$12.40 in early Monday trading following
the news of the CEO transition trading
well below its all-time low closing
price of
$12.90 set last
week previously a co-founder of Tinder
wolf herd founded the female oriented
Bumble in 2014 shortly after suing
Tinder for sexual
harassment but as bumble's market
capitalization slipped to below $2
billion wolf herd's Fortune took a
similar tumble tanking from a peak of
about $1.5 billion in early 2021 to $510
million as of this may Bumble which was
part of 2021s record setting year of
IPOs has experienced similar stock
declines to other companies that went
public during the boom period stepping
in as CEO will be lyan Jones Who
currently serves in the same capacity at
workplace messaging service
[Music]
Slack